a man whose football mourning in america
column is must read
material as it was once again today
peter king back on the rich eisenshow
how are you peter
rich eisen how are you i am doing better
for talking to you peter
um so let's let's get into it here um i
i agree with you
the aaron rodgers situation is quiet and
usually when it's quiet
after such a loud burst um
is you know not just because everybody's
back to their corners and digging in
uh something something's probably going
to be a foot if not now
uh the next week or so before
you know the june 1st um calendar hits
and then
mandatory mini camps may appear and then
be blown off and then this whole thing
gets
blown up again i'm wondering what you're
hearing about aaron rodgers and the
packers as you and i converse
here not a lot rich
i mean as i wrote my column i think that
uh that the two sides
are essentially
uh are trying to let things
simmer down and i mean the packers
obviously with their multiple troops out
to california
understand that there's a problem uh
obviously uh the uh
you know the packers understand that
that the relationship um is teetering
right now and but they have said
basically hey look we're not trading i
almost think
that if you know matt lafleur gets on
the
phone with aaron rodgers right now or
brian gooda const or mark murphy gets on
the phone with aaron rodgers or with
david dunn his agent
somebody might say something that they
might regret not not aaron necessarily
because
you know the team has to deal with him
so i kind of think we're in a little bit
as i wrote today of the calm after the
storm
i still can't believe it a year later
peter that this is getting to the point
where it is right now as you know mike
holmburn said he would never have
allowed it to happen with his star
player
ever and i still can't believe it like
as i said in the previous segment peter
that i
i lost track the number of times that my
wife and i have told our children all
under the age of 13 when they did
something and
our reaction was a certain way that they
did not like that what
what did you expect your consequence
to happen like your from your action
that gouda kunst
never gave rogers a heads up and never
spoke to him afterwards about it in the
immediate aftermath or attempted to and
got rebuffed like
is that really what happened like he
just thought i'm gonna trade up to go
get this guy
and then uh you know aaron will just be
the usual uh if you will
good soldier like did that really happen
do you i think for a long time
you know in packardom um
it's one of those deals that
you know the um the general manager
picks the players the coach coaches the
players and the players play
and there's not a lot of concern by the
front office
uh to say to the players hey listen
here's what we're doing and here's why
we're doing this
which to me and i i would be
very surprised if the packers
haven't already said something in their
meetings
with rogers and which is that they
haven't already said something like
okay we're going to be more open we're
going to be more transparent with you in
the future
blah blah blah because clear that's
that's the easiest thing to do and i
also wouldn't be surprised if
mark murphy will uh will intercede at
some point in the next month or so and
say okay
here here are the things here here is
the thing
or things that we're going to do to
change but you know rich you're right
you know for everyone who says
uh you know for everyone who says
basically
uh you know this is the way well this is
the way our business is my boss doesn't
come to me
even if i'm a a treasured employee my
boss doesn't come to me and said hey i
just want to warn you
here's what we're going to do next
here's a decision the company is making
and you know and i do understand that
this is really a different story because
this basically impinges or infringes
on aaron rodgers job you know the fact
that they're
taking a quarterback in the first round
and i get that
but so i think that mark murphy is going
to do
something to change the landscape or
offer to do something to change the
landscape
and we'll see if that's going to be
enough and i i don't i really don't
think it is but we'll see
no and in that regard um peter king here
on the rich eisen show
there was a conversation that what was
there already
uh a negotiation that fell apart that
that
wound up blowing up on draft day and uh
you know
i i don't ever want to get in the middle
of you know
who told adam schefter what and when he
told him and that you know that
that was front and center in our
business last week but
the only reason why it's germaine is
was there a negotiation that was going
on
that that blew up um and
and if so why i mean if if this is about
aaron getting the contractual
dollars and cents on the table that
would
um preclude them having the ability to
turn to jordan love
when they wanted to um then why would he
say no to something like that what it
what was going on behind the scenes that
led to
i don't know i don't know the answer to
that other than to say
that i was told by somebody who i
trust would know that this is not about
his contract
this is about other things now i'm sure
that
i'm sure that there is some
dissatisfaction with the contract based
on everything that is involved here
but but again rich my only
the only knowledge i have is before i
wrote last monday
i was told by somebody i trusted
that this is about the way
rogers is treated and the way that the
organization handles him
not about his contract so
again i could be wrong on that
that's what i was told and we'll see how
big a factor the contract is going down
the road well the only reason why i
bring up the contract is because soon
guaranteed money is gone and that allows
more flexibility for the team to say
goodbye to him although
he still has a say in where he gets to
go i understand all that but
again and this is why terry bradshaw my
estimation peter was so
off about equating you know mark malone
being drafted as a first-rounder while
he was
you know eventually i guess it turned
out to be three years four seasons
removed from his
last season and he kind of said you know
i i wouldn't didn't pay that any money
and aaron shouldn't pay that any mind i
that
they're the finances are different and
you know the way that teams build
championships in the nfl right now
is either go the tom brady route or
trying to win with an
older quarterback who's still quite uh
terrific like what green bay's trying to
do
sure can i just can i tell you can i
tell you why i don't really think it's
about
the contrast please go for it because
because
okay so aaron rodgers just had an mvp
season had won the greatest seasons of
his life
if aaron rodgers has another one of the
greatest seasons of his life
this year and jordan love doesn't get on
the field except to play some in the
preseason
do you think there's any chance in the
world
that the packers after this season
would trade aaron rodgers or would
somehow part ways with aaron rodgers no
that's why i don't i i and again look
i don't know i i'm just telling you i
don't know
all i know is that i try to sort of
think of what happens and
everybody who keeps saying that well
there's no guaranteed money after this
year the packers can just get rid of
them
the packers are going to get rid of him
if he stinks but he's not going to stink
you know he's he's not going to stink
now look if he gets hurt and jordan love
comes in and plays great
then probably he's gone i get that
but under this under the circumstances
that we are faced with
now if aaron rodgers plays like aaron
rodgers
and plays a full 17-game season
or very close to it the green bay
packers
are not getting rid of aaron rodgers
yeah it doesn't make sense
but then what it's not it's not sensible
right so
um last one for you on the subject
matter then is
then what does aaron rodgers want i mean
is it gouda kun's head on
on on a pike like uh ned stark spoiler
alert to use that
every look you know what aaron rodgers
is too
smart to want gouda conspired right
because
because if he gets let's just
say for the sake of argument let's just
say
right that uh that
the green bay packers announce tomorrow
that brian guticans has been fired
and uh you know and we're doing this
because we want to pave the way for
aaron or
however they would announce it okay just
imagine that
okay as i wrote in my column today
brian goodacon since taking over as
general manager in his three years
the packers have a better record than
the new england patriots
okay and what would aaron rodgers be
known
for he'd be known for running a general
manager
out of town who's got a record of
whatever like 34 and 17.
you know he he doesn't want to do that
that's why i i look
i i rich i'm going to just tell you this
i do not have
a direct pipeline to aaron rodgers i'm
not pat mcafee i'm just
i'm just simply trying to read
tea leaves and when i heard that rogers
wants uh
brian gutican's fired maybe he does want
brian guticans fired and so
i'm just saying i'm saying to you
absolutely unequivocally i could be
wrong
but to me aaron rodgers would have his
fingerprints
all over the firing of a general manager
who's 34 and 17 in his three years
and what sense does that make
you know i i just i just don't see it i
i just don't see it
peter king here on the rich eisen show
another aspect of your of your piece
today in football morning in america
which you could see
on uh on pro football talk nbc sports
nbcsports.com
um was the odds that you had for
a new deshaun watson home should he
prove to emerge
from what we in the nfl media refer to
his situation as a viable
nfl quarterback or viable citizen um
and with put it all together
um why do you choose 2022
as the possibility is there no do you
know what
what what are you hearing that makes you
think 2021 i i i'm not
i mean all i'm hearing is that
i think most people around the nfl
believe
that deshaun watson's season this year
is going to be interrupted by either
trials or a suspension
or both and so
that's why i say
here's my best guesses for where he's
going to be in 2022.
maybe he'll be somewhere in 2021 but
don't you think right now until
all of his legal stuff is played out and
until
the nfl rules in some way
how in the world if you're an owner of a
franchise how is your jeffrey lurie
right now do you
stand at a press conference and announce
that you have just traded
for uh a guy who has been accused by
whatever 21 or 22 women of sexual
assault or sexual harassment whatever
whatever the
the courses say the case is exactly say
i just you can't do it so i mean
i i put 2022 in there for a very simple
reason that
i just think his 2021 season is a
washout
and so um i you know the the concept of
the eagles being
being sitting at the top of your list of
of
of um you know odds on the next football
team you have philadelphia three to one
i mean
they've got all those first-round picks
right i put it straight to howie roseman
last week
you know trying to keep him away from
getting topped for tampering
but you know um the way that they've
attempted
you know the jalen hurts the way that
the coach is sitting here saying there's
a quarterback competition with joe
flacco
because they just got there it's clear
to me that hertz has got a year to
figure this thing out
in philadelphia because if not it's
sitting right there
jalen hurts has the job in his hands if
he plays great if he is
uh dak prescott this year right then
i doubt the eagles are going to go get a
quarterback and then they will have the
true luxury of
having a quarterback on his rookie deal
for the next two years now they can't
have it for three
they you know because he was a second
round pick but they can
they can they can have a quarterback on
a rookie deal
with all of these high picks and
probably two years from now the money to
spend in free agency
on missing pieces they'd be in fat city
if jalen hurts as a really good player
but you know i think it's probably more
likely than not not
certain but more likely than not that
they'll be looking for a quarterback
uh you know at some point this year or
next
so that's why i put them there they've
got all the resources to do so but
i mean i had them tied with carolina
because i think
if if they decide that they want to go
get this player they're going to be very
very aggressive in trying to do so well
i think it's also wise for you peter to
look at the other conference because you
know that's where houston would want to
send him and we we also know that watson
again uh this is all um
assuming that he does emerge this
through this as a viable quarterback and
citizen of the world
washington would be i mean just a
dynamite spot because they also didn't
really go in a direction this year
other than to look at 2021 right they
didn't they
didn't go that's why those three teams
are my top three teams
uh in this because they all um
look like they could need quarterbacks
in 2022
and all of them each one of them
uh have very aggressive front offices
and or
uh an owner and so all of them
i think this this really could be
especially if the desean watson
outcome is not as bad as everyone thinks
it
it it looks right now if if
then they're going to have it's like you
know i wrote about the dolphins
at the top of my column one of the
things i said about chris greer
is how he uses leverage he used leverage
to get a great deal out of houston for
laramie tonsil
and he used leverage to get a really
good deal out of the 49ers for the third
pick in the draft
smart teams know how to use leverage and
i'm pretty sure that
nick casario worked under bill belichick
for 20 years
and knows how to use leverage and i i
mean this is all speculation again peter
and i
you know normally you and i don't live
in this realm but
but it is still out there and it's stuff
that i hear and i'm sure
you know you're hearing it too you know
the the dolphins
still have a hankering for desean watson
and if not vice versa you know uh will
fuller
is now on that team um and
and again the fact that the texans took
a kid
with their first draft choice this year
i mean with all their holes to fill
come to me puts the writing completely
one pick in the top
80. please one very chosen
and they pick a quarterback and nick
casario says
in essence oh that doesn't mean anything
it doesn't
this is not anything about sean watson
please that's through it
that's not that's the why right and the
fact that we have not heard
okay because you know you have to assume
let's put it that way let's let's live
in the realm of again
assumption and speculation that watson
and his
team want out of houston immediately and
want to turn the page
immediately if they possibly can and do
it this year they don't want to sit
around
and have davis mills and rod taylor take
his job while he's sitting around in a
in a as you said
in a in a court proceeding or if he is
going to take a suspension from the nfl
do it right away but with a new team
where he's already with new teammates
and he can already do what he usually
does which is ingratiate himself into a
new community and it's
and it's good works um put it all
together
you know that there's going to be that
sort of want and desire from watson's
team the fact that we have not heard
from a lawyer who has put everything on
instagram the minute this thing
came free makes me think that there
might be
something happening with watson trying
to settle
and that's why this is quiet this is
very very quiet right now
especially when there's a lawyer
involved who could not
put more on his instagram account to put
pressure on watson who i think wants
this thing done with right now i'm
wondering what you're hearing
about all that that you're not trying to
share you know rich i hate to say it i'm
not really covering the story
i'm i'm just not it's uh you know
i'm just not i'm not doing very much
with the story right
and so i have not had nose to the ground
about
why is it so quiet but what you're
saying makes total sense
that's why i'm saying it's completely
speculative peter you know and and i
and i know you don't usually it's it's
speculative but it is sensible
so um put it all together and you know
those are the two biggest stories that
we have
is there another one that we're missing
in this offseason that
as we're hitting the schedule on
wednesday what could be happening is it
a
another quarterback situation that could
come before
the only other thing that really
interests me right now is
you know how will jimmy garoppolo play i
think he's going to start the season
with the niners
uh and we'll start as the starting
quarterback
and then we'll see how long he hangs on
to his job he might hang on to it for
the full year
he drives them deep in the playoffs i
don't i think the 49ers will keep him
next year that's amazing but
you know everything right there because
i believe if they had gotten a great
offer for him on draft day or draft
weekend they would have they would have
taken it
but um that's the other story i think
that's really interesting right now
what happens at quarterback in san
francisco peter i really appreciate the
time
thank you so much as always no problem
rich enjoyed it right back
thanks peter that's peter king right
here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here